ce matin avec nous gilbert collard
député européen du rassemblement
national gilbert collard bienvenu merci
d'être avec nous dans la matinale de rtl
france pour commencer peut-être votre
réaction est ce que ça vous choque que
le chef de l'état puissent avoir recours
à des cabinets de conseils pour se faire
conseiller justement notamment dans la
stratégie vaccinale d'évidence oui
surtout quand on remonte l'historique
des liens entre ce cabinet mckinsey et
la macro ni et monsieur macro je vois
pas je vois pas vraiment ce que le
cabinet privé payé quand même sauf
erreur de ma part deux millions d'euros
par mois peut apporter dans la lutte
contre la pandémie
on a une prolifération de d'institutions
on a une épidémie si j'ose dire de
spécialistes en tous genres on a des
réunions en permanence on a des services
d'état démultiplier qui se consacre à la
lutte contre la pandémie et on se
demande ce qu'un cabinet aux intérêts
quand même ramifié à la macro ni et au
président de la république vient faire
là dedans il faut aussi s'intéresser aux
personnes qui se trouvent dans ce dans
ce cabinet bon sauf erreur de ma part il
ya quand même des proches de quelques
personnalités politiques bien connues
bon tout cela sent très mauvais et dans
cette période d'inquiétude d'angoise de
craintes sur la manière dont la gestion
de la crise pandémique est faite pose
évidemment problème il ya quelque chose
de pourri dans le dans le dans le
royaume de la lutte contre la pandémie
qu'est ce qu'une caisse qu'elle qu'est
ce qu'un cabinet privé peut apporter
dans dans la lutte sanitaire contre une
pandémie ou dans la question qu'il faut
se poser alors vous parler d'inquiétude
de l'inquiétude des dirigeants de mu et
elle est importante roselyne bachelot
les reçoit justement aujourd'hui pour
étudier un an
éventuelle réouverture alors selon vous
les musées les lieux de culture est ce
qu'ils me doivent rouvrir aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on devrait de quelques fois
très franc 1 quitte à me faire me faire
rabrouer
je pense que le confinement hélas compte
tenu et je le regrette de la gestion
s'imposera à un moment donné ou un autre
mail erreur gravissime humainement
impardonnable qui a été commise par le
pouvoir
bien conseillé comme vous avez pu le
constater c'est d'avoir fait un
confinement global un confinement
holistique sans aucune application
malléable intelligente
franchement c'est pas dans les musées
que le plus grand nombre d'hommes et de
femmes de femmes et d'enfants se
réunissent hélas pourrait-on dire
mais s'il ya un lieu où la distance ou
la quantité de personnes n'est pas
inquiétante du point de vue de la
propagation d'un virus c'est bien
aiguisé et c'est quand même tout à fait
dommage que les lieux de culture qui
sont pas des lieux d'affluence en ces
bons soit l'objet d'une fermeture alors
qu'ils auraient pu faire l'objet d'un
d'un confinement intelligent c'est à
dire avec des mesures barrières avec une
jauge approprié avec des distances avec
une ventilation on parle pas assez de
l'aération les allemands 6 ans
intéressés s'y intéresse c'est un moyen
extrêmement efficace aussi de lutter
contre la contamination mais c'est un
problème qui n'a pas encore été abordée
en france les allemands eux se
préoccupent de l'aération des lieux pour
éviter la stagnation du virus alors avec
cette crise sanitaire on entend beaucoup
ces dernières semaines des voix demandé
un retour à la souveraineté économique
voyez ce qu'a déclaré agnès panière une
hache ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de l'économie
je peux vous annoncer aujourd'hui que
nous avons relancé un appel à projet de
300 millions d'euros pour permettre de
fabriquer plus en france pas seulement
des vaccins d'ailleurs mais également
des traitements
alors voilà fabriquer plus en france des
vaccins n'est pas seulement des
traitements c'est une bonne chose un bon
cap pris par le gouvernement pour vous
mais c'est effrayant de constater que
c'est maintenant alors que que la
pandémie est installée qui se rendent
compte qu'ils se rendent compte de
l'importance de la souveraineté
économique pharmaceutique territoriale
dire on a l'impression qu'ils dormaient
jusqu'à présent et alors ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est le culot avec
lequel ils viennent annoncer la
nécessité de faire ce qu'ils n'ont pas
fait depuis qu'ils sont au pouvoir
ça relève vraiment de deux gourous de la
bêtise ou de la schizophrénie ou
simplement de la moquerie politique
comment peuvent-ils venir maintenant
après les longues nous les longs mois de
pandémie nous dire ah on s'est réveillé
ce matin on s'est rendu compte que il
faut quand même qu'on ait une certaine
souveraineté
ce sont des incapables qu'est ce que je
vous dise bon le i ce qu'ils avaient le
temps de depuis qu'on leur on le redit
l'importance de la souveraineté dans
tous les domaines du reste de se
réveiller s'organiser je suis consterné
de voir à quel point ce pouvoir est
ensommeillés alors en sommeil mais pas
pour verbaliser parce qu'il ya eu une
annonce qui a qui a fait grincer des
dents vacances ou pas il faudra
s'organiser pour ne pas rouler après 18
heures sinon c'est la verbalisation est
ce que c'est normal au fond selon vous
après n'être finalement pour faire
respecter le couvre-feu dans le cas de
faire une règle il faut la respecter
mais il faut appliquer ce qu'on appelait
autrefois dans l'armée la théorie des
baïonnettes intelligente
il faut il faut faire comprendre aux
fonctionnaires de police qu'ils ont une
marge d'appréciation en fonction de la
situation humaine
voilà ce qui est insupportable c'est de
se faire contrôler par exemple est
verbalisé quand on a trois minutes de
retard c'est pas ce n'est pas un excès
de vitesse le le fait de dépasser
l'heure du confinement de quelques
minutes
ou alors en ayant un motif acceptable il
faut il faut vraiment que on est
un confinement horaires intelligent et
qu'on dise aux fonctionnaires de police
qu'ils ont une marge d'appréciation dans
la halle amendes qu'ils vont délivrer
bon à force de systématiser robotisée
finalement toutes les mesures que l'on
veut prendre ça confine à des situations
qui sont absurdes et est insupportable
pour l'opinion publique totalement
insupportable alors tout cas une bonne
chose que les français puissent partir
en vacances en restriction de
déplacement mais moi je crois que c'est
une soupape de de sécurité psychologique
le pouvoir se rend compte que les
françaises et les français d'abord à
cause d'une incompréhension absolue dans
laquelle il se trouve de tout ce qui se
passe et ensuite par le corset de ces
mesures n'en peuvent plus
n'en peuvent plus moi les gens que je
rencontre me disent qu'ils sont
asphyxiés
hier hier j'ai rencontré un de mes amis
qui quittent qui les larmes aux yeux m'a
raconté que il a attendu quinze jours
avant que sa mère soit soient inhumés
bon et on m'a raconté également d'une
malheureuse qui avait fait un infarctus
mais qu'il y avait de la fièvre au
prétexte de la fièvre a été dirigée dans
le service co vide alors que le réduit à
néant cardiologie bon voilà et elle est
morte un bon on est en train on est en
train de de de faire cohabiter
l'absurdité avec la règle hélas cette
prof des effets kafkaïen effroyable
poids et puis soyons francs
cette endémie avait pas gérer passait au
jour le jour c'est en fonction de
l'atmosphère politique en fonction des
craintes électorale en fonction des
intérêts aussi parce que ce cabinet
mckinsey qui arrive comme ça pour donner
des conseils
ça me paraît tout à fait suspect on a
l'impression qu'on se rend des services
quoique on se renvoie l'ascenseur pour
l'échafaud c'est insupportable alors
autre actualité qui cristallise le débat
ces derniers jours c'est le projet de
loi sur le séparatisme il continue à
être débattu à l'assemblée
on a appris qu'un professeur de
philosophie a été placé sous protection
policière pour avoir alerté sur la
progression de l'emprise communautaire
islamistes
dans la commune de trappes ce projet de
loi est ce que ça a abondé bout un bon
début par non selon vous pour lutter
contre toute forme de radicalité
finalement alors c'est surtout une bonne
cuite
quand vous pensez que que monsieur
d'arbanats indique que dick dynamise n'a
pas d'identité n'a pas de frontières et
n'a pas de religion c'est c'est le
contraire de tout ce qu'il faut dire
on est alerté depuis longtemps vous
savez quand dans un pays on dit qu'à des
zones de non droit qui a des quartiers
perdus de la république quand on a tous
les livres témoignage courageux d'un
proviseur marseillais par exemple
intitulé proviseur aux imams de la
république quand on alloue ouvrage d'un
ancien inspecteur de l'éducation
nationale qui s'interrogent sur la
manière dont l'islam a pu pénétrer
l'école bon quand on lit le livre les le
maire et les barbares sur la manière
dont l'islam politique arrive à
maîtriser quelque part des élections
dont on se rend bien compte qu'on est
arrivé à un point où il faut être
maintenant d'une fermeté est légal bien
sûr conventionnelle extrême et la
première question qu'on n'ose pas
aborder
c'est bien évidemment celle de
l'immigration parce que c'est par le
biais de l'immigration incontrôlée par
le biais des abus des droits à
l'immigration
on se trouve en situation on n'arrive
plus à contrôler et à réguler et
assimilés à maîtriser et on se trouve
maintenant dans une phase paroxystique
critiquer ce qui est courageux c'est que
des hommes s'expose des femmes s'expose
au risque pour dénoncer ce que les
politiques auraient dû depuis longtemps
dénoncé ce que nous avons fait nous mais
nous on se faisait insulter ont été des
fachos on était des réacs
on était des islamophobes ont été des
xénophobes alors qu'on disait simplement
qu'il y avait
un danger qui ne faisait que croître et
maintenant le danger est installé
gilbert collard avant de conclure
peut-être un mot sur la proportionnelle
françois bayrou s'est exprimé à ce sujet
regardez vous réagissez la
proportionnelle est une obligation
démocratique et moral
notre démocratie est bloqué les français
y adhèrent de moins en moins des
millions d'électeurs ne sont pas
représentés au parlement parce que leur
vote va des partis minoritaires
c'est une injustice inacceptable cimer
collard en quelques mots vous le
soutenez sur ce coup là françois bayrou
devant demandes répétées penser car vous
pensez qu'avec le nombre de millions et
de millions et de millions d'électeurs
on a une passe est de députés ce qui est
à proprement parler
la négation de la démocratie on a une
démocratie d'apparence en a pas une
démocratie de réalité il est bien
évident que la proportionnelle
permettrait peut-être au parlement de
retrouver sa voie de sortir de son info
ni démocratique mais à mon avis il est
trop tard maintenant pour que le
président de la république aille vers la
proportionnelle même si c'est une cire
pour lutter contre la 6e' démocratique
qui nous étreint il n'y a que la
proportionnelle qui ramènerait dans
l'hémicycle dans l'enceinte
parlementaire la réalité de la
représentation du pays ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui c'est un théâtre
d'ombrés théâtre de de répétiteur
politique le parlement aujourd'hui ils
ne représentent strictement plus rien
une chambre d'enregistrement
merci beaucoup gilbert collard d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes de
députés européens du rassemblement
national